у дупі в руку махнула петля
нідерландського референдуму ще до води
просто зв'язки між україною та єс
спробуй референдум був у рекомендацій
на лише 22 сотки на сцені я сказала не
асоціації
прем'єр-міністр Нідерланди слухаючи номер
про ратифікацію документ для чого слова та
компроміс миша [ __ ] брюсселем та києвом
на судно в руку в Нідерландах
парламентські вибори і адже партії
кеа гід вали про ти референдумом тепер
ви знаєте результат
треба ворог ого ти забув би сама губ
для політичних партій треба слухати
до сюди думки своїх громадян я думаю що
це урок для нас тут у присіли за словами
& katty perry я килика варіанті
розрізання проблеми на і радикальний
варіант нідерланди заходи тофік піти воду
і переговорний процес моя чомусь я
спочатку з категорично треба що ви київ
ns подоба тяжкості вкрай є ці вже
давно ратифікацію воду напиши
компромісний варіант газу схожий у тебе
на догоду алоіс за 100 рідше за нього і диво
ризиковий кооперації з Україною у
фінансову допомогла і ось вона про давнє
всі сатина передача
та автоматичних у членства України в ес
євро депутат вигляд білизну marco de mis
mapper призначаємо ще один нюанс j sports
торгівлі нарахованої води цієї години
воді та nemo та дати ув'язнення
те що еротично c може ревати б
Скинеш та ще й таким собі парадокс
uncle і засовується у року про
асоціацію без офіційної ратифікації
the fleet чи у воду про асоціацію між
україною та ес но будинок до вугілля до chef
може розділитися на україні част енакін
не вимагатимуть ратифікації економічно
bespeco ось аполітичним в team ціни вла
що ви вони ки вони брюссель